how often do you have a random thought
to think where did that come from
chances are it's not as random as you
might think your thoughts are influenced
by information that is obtained from the
world around you and filtered through
all of your past memories sometimes
thoughts that may seem completely random
could actually be your mind
unconsciously recalling information that
is closely linked in your memory for
example if your friend asks you to name
a random fruit while at the same time
they're talking about their brand-new
yellow car and they're matching yellow
driving cap your brain is primed with
the word yellow so even though there's a
wide variety of fruits you're more
likely to jump to the word banana
okay go she helped feather number one he
ate the banana she held the feather the
dog loves benches
she has webbed feet crumbs are never
left the kids were swimming the Sun is
hot Sofia wasn't it an animal ducks duck
duck Duck Duck
oh okay what it didn't work I was gonna
say duck was my first instinct I look
under your seat
you
what just happened
well look back of ISM hate the banana
yellow she held the feather feathers the
dog loves benches I don't get that one
she has webbed feet okay a duck only
crumbs are left feeding the Ducks the
kids were swimming in a pond the Sun is
hot at the pond where the Ducks swimming
you know what it was in my mind duck was
one of the words that I used and I was
like I don't want to use a word that's
on here whoa
mind games uh this is a hippo duck what
the hell yeah science is crazy this is
also adorable